الكاظمي يفجر مفاجاه حول جثماني صدام حسين
رساله طمانه من الخزانه الامريكيه بعد
انهيار بنك سيليكون والطيران رياض ناقل
وطني جديد في السعوديه هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في اول تصريح له بعد خروجه من الحكومه اكد
رئيس الوزراء العراقي السابق مصطفى
الكاظمي في مقابله مع صحيفه الشرق الاوسط
ان جثمان الرئيس العراقي الاسبق صدام حسين
كان مرميا بين منزله ومنزل نور المالكي في
المنطقه الخضراء بعد اعدامه مباشره الكاظم
الخلاي ايضا انه تم نبشه قبر صدام حسين
عقب السيطره داعش على المنطقه وان نقلت
الجثه الى مكان سري لا يعرفه احد حتى الان
كما انه تم العبث بقبر ولديه عدي وقصي
رغم وصفها الازمه بالصادمه نفت وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه جاني ان تكون الصعوبات
في قطاع التكنولوجيا سببا في انهيار بنك
سيليكون فالي مؤكده ان مرور احد البنوك
بازمه لا يعني ان بقيه البنوك ستعاني وان
اقتصاد البلد اكدت بانه
افلاس بنك سيليكون فالي هرع الموادعون الى
فروعه لسحب اموالهم فيما اكدت وسائل اعلام
امريكيه انه الافلاس الامريكيه الاكبر في
الولايات المتحده منذ الازمه الماليه عامه
في السعوديه اعلن ولي العهد الامير محمد
بن سلمان عن تاسيس صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه لشركه طيران الرياض كناقل جوي وطني
جديد والذي سيربط العاصمه السعوديه باكثر
من 100 وجهه عالميه بحلول عام
2030 الشركه الجديده ستتخذ من العاصمه
الرياض مركزا رئيسا لاداره عمليتها
التشغيليه
ومنطلقا لرحلاتها عبر امتلاك اسطول
الطائرات متطوره تستهدف من خلاله تطبيق
افضل ممارسات الاستدامه والسلامه المعتمده
عالميا في مجال الطيران الى جانب توفير
احدث التقنيات الرقميه للرياده في هذا
المجال
نختم من الولايات المتحده حيث كشف تقريرنا
لصحيفه
لبناء مدينه خاصه بموظف شركته تقرير
الصحيفه وصف المدينه التي سيبنيها ماسك
بالفاضله وقال ان ماسك يخطط التاجير بل
لتاجير منازله للعمال بسعر يقل عن السوق
المحليه بكثير حيث سيكون سعر استئجار منزل
مكون من غرفتين نوم 800 دولار شهريا
مقارنه ب 2200 دولار في مدينه باستروب
المجاوره